small pharmacies across the country are
quickly
becoming a critical part of vaccine
distribution there are about 23 000
independent pharmacies in this country
and many are the backbone of their
community
now they are stepping up to fight
misinformation and administer the
vaccine in areas where medical resources
are often limited
maria villarreal shows us how one
independent pharmacy
is leading the way taking care of
patients is the ultimate goal of a
community pharmacist
you have a preference to which army
you'd like to have it in stephen
hofford's career as a pharmacist
brought him back home to magnolia texas
where the population is
just over 2 000 people does it make it
extra special knowing that this
is where you grew up and you're giving
back to your own town
yes it's it's it's real heartfelt have
you ever had any kind of a low energy
reaction
at the beginning of the pandemic hofford
stepped up to make hand sanitizer for
those on the front lines
now he's stepping up again by
distributing 500 doses of the moderna
vaccine
we have great relationships with our
community so being able to make sure
that we're able to get those patients in
on a timely manner
it's a challenge but it's something
we're working through every day texas is
currently vaccinating group
1b which in this state is residents 65
and older
and people 16 and older with medical
conditions that could put them at risk
for severe illness with covet 19. i
survived
20 20. jane ball will be 85 years old
next month
[Music]
ba's son is an anesthesiologist he said
mom
you could have been in the emergency
room with me or the icu
and seeing all the people i have put to
sleep
paralyzed intubated you would run to get
this vaccination
big pharmacy chains like cvs and
walgreens contracted with the federal
government
to help distribute vaccines but those
chains
aren't always in rural communities
leaving independent pharmacies to fill
in the gaps with both access to quality
care
and factual education on vaccinations
hofford says they're doing 50 shots a
day until they run out
i called my own doctor they aren't
giving the shots
so i tried some of the local
big big chain pharmacies they're not
giving the shots
bill haynes is over 65 diabetic and
hopeful the vaccine will make
a swift impact i'm going to be happy to
be able to see people smile
within eight hours of opening up
appointments for vaccinations
hoffert says all 500 were booked
do you feel like your whole career is
kind of led up to this point of being
kind of the center point for the
distribution process i would say so it's
like the super bowl man it was talk to
talked up talked up
that day is here
of the more than 377 thousand vaccines
that have been given out here in texas
more than 56 thousand have been given
inside pharmacies of all sizes
hoffer believes however that small
pharmacies will continue to play a
big role in the distribution system
which is why he asked pharmacy students
certified in administering the vaccine
to come in and help with the demand
anthony
maria as we've said so many people
waiting for that vaccine and we're
behind in delivering it
so important what he's doing there thank
you very much